we're officially out of the endgame now
people and it feels oh so good after a
year of not feeling so good mr. stark
Avengers endgame has released and as of
this taping is certified fresh' at 96%
on the tomato meter which makes it
competitive with Black Panther as the
most critically acclaimed ncu film thus
far
like we said as of right now reviews are
still trickling in it is 96% black
panthers 97% if you want the latest and
greatest the score head over to
rottentomatoes.com
to keep updated hello everyone and
welcome to the after-show where we're
gonna review analyze and spoil
everything about Avengers end games so I
hope you've seen the movie or you don't
care about knowing what happens my name
is Mark Ellis and I'm thrilled to be
joined today by Jacqueline Coley Scott
mance and Maude Garrett to talk about
the greatest comic book event that our
eyes have ever seen we did it gang 11
years this is the twenty second movie
we're here now and so I'd love to get
everybody's take just what do you think
of the film Jack when they just say
fresh movie absolutely positively fresh
I thought it was a great movie and
thoroughly enjoyable even though it was
three hours I had a good time three
hours and I know the p-brane might have
hit some people harder than others Scott
to be able to were you able to make it
through the whole film I've made it
through the whole film okay so yeah is
it fresh of course it's fresh but the
question is can they make a bigger
paddle because this movie is so
certified fresh I can't even take it
this movie exceeded every hope and every
expectation that I had for this final
film in this massive groundbreaking
trailblazing series that started back in
2008 at the end of the first Ironman
when Nick Fury shows up in this bonus
credit scene to recruit Tony Stark for
the Avengers initiative NASA pay off
very very satisfying he's going fresh
mod would you like to be the contrarian
for all the Internet to witness commit
social suicide absolutely no this is
very fresh this is so good in fact my
favorite part about this movie is seeing
it early and everyone going
oh my buddy's ready for this and me
tweeting back going it's not really
you're not prepared for this movie it's
great I loved it I think that you can
prepare yourself for seeing the film and
getting excited about it over a decade
plus the movies all leading up to this
one moment but it's hard to be
emotionally prepared for what you're
going to witness in Avengers endgame
what we've already seen you have Tony
Stark not gonna be around anymore
Natasha black widowed not gonna be her
on cap is now an old man and he seems
like he's leaning towards retirement he
gives his shield over to Sam mod was
there one moment that stuck out to you
that was the emotional core the crux the
one that really got the tear ducts
everything to do with cap I have gone
through like the Chris phases of a
lifetime here because all the hot Chris
souvenirs cap is now my man I think that
they did such a beautiful story with him
and the way that he was able to live out
his entire life's dream this man had his
future taken away from him and he had to
leave the love of his life behind in a
different decade and like I think the
fact that he spent his whole life
serving his country and the world and
the galaxy and the fact that when he was
given the choice he was able to go back
and put love first was so beautiful
making me emotion let's talk about this
guy he got to dance with his who with it
with his girl his his steady girl Peggy
was at that moment for you or was it
Tony saying goodbye for the last time
well well that was a big huge emotional
moment because it was one that I I
didn't see coming
and I you know there were certain things
about the film I had a feeling about I
felt like with Tony Stark and Iron Man
dying
it'll look it started with Iron Man it
ended with Iron Man and I had a feeling
that he was gonna die the moment you're
talking about with Captain America but
for me it was a much smaller moment I am
a huge spider-man fan I have always been
a huge spider-man fan I love the sort of
father figure aspect that Tony Stark
plates at Peter Parker and spider-man
homecoming and I really felt like that
moment when Peter Parker comes back he
goes oh mr. stark should see where we
were and Tony Stark is just so happy
that he just gives him a big hug there
was that little moment that got to me
because I grew up with spider-man and it
was such a great moment something that
we really didn't even see in the comics
this relationship between spider-man and
I it's an excellent point because it's
not just Iron Man leaving us it's all
those little moments
leading up to a Tim greeting spider-man
again and then at the end when Spiderman
comes up to him as Peter Parker and he's
and he's saying goodbye to Tony Stark
and then he gets about five seconds and
then Pepper Potts comes out it's like
okay this is my guy you stand aside all
right sit down son they've like been
together for a while and they've got a
kid yeah yeah yeah I think the way that
we leave the movie where we see oh okay
now we see an old Steve Rogers and he's
passing the shield on to Sam and then we
have Tony Stark leaving the leaving his
body we might still get him in some sort
of voiceover form in a spider suit in
the future which a lot of people
theorized but you kind of forget leaving
the movie that we lost Black Widow Tzu
and what an epic scene that was her and
Hawkeye kind of fighting for the right
to throw themselves off this cliff
Monda that and give you an emotional
tinge at all the disrespect was rife did
you not like that either I did not I did
not like that at all I was not a fan did
we have to do a parallel of women giving
up what they needed for men again like
and I get what for me personally I felt
that that moment was just the Russo
brothers trying to keep people guessing
because everyone assumed that Hawkeye
was going to die in fact personally in
my opinion the things that worked less
for me were moments where I felt they
did it not necessarily because that's
the logical place to go but that's where
they wanted to go to keep people
guessing like to me personally honestly
thought cap should have been the one to
die if we really look at the fact that
he's really sort of the the heart of the
Avengers and Tony's more of the brain
and like the soul behind it so of course
he would be the ultimate sacrifice yes
it's a bit on the nose and a very sort
of like dying for my people type of way
but he to me should have been the one to
die but you know I think the way they
did Tony was great but the Black Widow
thing that to me just felt throwaway it
was so being it from day one she has
been alongside Iron Man alongside cap
she's been there from the start you know
and I think that to just be like no I
want to die mall I gotta say well first
you know she made her first appearance
in Ironman to back in 2000 and it was a
beautiful amazing scene and that's
probably most powerful we've seen him
you know and that moment you know when
when I was thinking back to the
characters that died in Avengers endgame
it took me a second to remember oh yeah
Black Widow died because her send-off
was not memorable it was not significant
it was not a word
he sent off its [ __ ] in Hawkeye yeah I
mean he murdered like everyone like he
was literally out on that haircut
I mean I get it I do get it that is the
way you go
I think it's there's a really great
quote my friend from Alonza from the rap
had in his review where he talked about
Marvel doesn't always give you what you
want it gives you what you need and we
needed to see one of the more expendable
original Avengers leave us and we needed
to see one of the top so we knew it was
gonna be cap and Iron Man and either
Hawkeye and black widow that was always
the way that it went and I think what we
wanted I think a lot of people maybe not
you guys but like myself I actually
wanted to see cap do that ultimate
sacrifice I felt that was his job and
seeing Tony do it felt a little weird
but I still think they did it well well
yeah I did it I did a poll on Twitter
where I was saying okay which adventure
do you think is gonna die and I listed
Iron Man I listened to Captain America
and and Thor and I forget who else and a
lot most people predicted that Captain
America was going to be the one to die
you know in terms of Marvel giving us
what we need this movie gave us a whole
lot more than what we need because I
mean I definitely agree with your point
about Black Widow that was a waste of
death but there were so many other
aspects of the film that gave us things
that we didn't even know that we needed
you know things that were really truly
surprising for example jumping ahead
five years I think a bold move I
literally audibly would you could feel
the theater there was a micro now we're
in a totally different world and
everything is unpredictable and I want
to get into all that time-travel stuff
and whether we buy into that or there's
just a new way that we can do
time-traveling movies before that though
I think something that we were not
surprised that that we did need going
back to your point Jacqueline was the
Avengers Assemble moment yeah right the
and it's this huge battle and it's just
maybe the most epic thing we've ever
seen in the history of cinema right and
that's the one thing that I would say
when we were talking to a lot of the
folks a lot of the cast members being
like I don't know what I was doing
can you imagine them filming that like
they're not looking at anything that is
all CGI like like chadwick boseman shows
up does maybe three lines with Sheree
and AK oh yeah
heck does he know anything that happens
at in game of course he doesn't know
anything that happens at any game I do
think that was great but Avengers
Assemble was awesome and
again half of the movie stars on the
planet showing up kicking butt like you
don't even know where to look the next
time if you get to watch it again don't
watch the main action start to look to
the right on the left because then you
will see like the side battles and the
side fights that you can't really pull
out on that first time view you know the
interesting thing about the Avengers
Assemble moment is it was a great and
with the way Catherine Eddowes Avengers
Assemble like he just like put a lot of
gusto behind that when he said that but
if you look at the fight scenes in
avengers endgame the ratio of fight
scenes to the running time of the movie
is actually very very low compared to
like all the other movies in the MCU
especially infinity war infinity war was
all battles exactly and that's why I
think the Russo brothers really made a
wise decision to really kind of scale
all that back and get into the emotion
getting thee into the family aspect of
the Avengers and also at the existential
aspect of them you know when you jump
ahead five years there they are a mess
without each other they fall apart
especially Thor what did he let himself
I mean before we get into a labelled ski
Thor which is definitely one of my
favorite movies of it but ya know III
the thing I remark tabat most was the
cost the cost of what these guys have to
be these superheroes and the cost not
that they felt on themselves but the
people around them the cost Don pepper
the cost for you know Paul Rudd as far
as like wasp and leaving them all of the
ancillary people the cost of his
daughter of you know losing that time
with him it's all of the side people
that I think we got to see that like
yeah these guys are superheroes but
there is there's a monetary loss for
them having to go and say let's go save
the world and seeing like Tony after you
know he loses for the first time and
Thor to me was the best one because of
course the spoiled little rich boy
prince
who's never felt any adversity that he
couldn't overcome I mean even in
Ragnarok he's still somehow managed to
win even though he lost so when he first
really gets beaten for the very first
time and there's no way for him the
magic or sort of like finagle his way
out of it of course it broke him and of
course it made him gain like 4000 that I
think lasted just a little bit you think
the entire battle scene whence you want
so
demise and he's like you know sucking
moment just lasted a bit too long I get
it Australians love beer I think this is
like this is some internalized shade
like to be known I feel you cuz like
there was a little bit much on how drunk
he was but he was a drunken lunch but by
the time we get to that end Avengers
Assemble scene right and we see him it
was really one of my favorite moments in
that battle is watching him and cap kind
of did trade because now cap can wield
the hammer and so Thor's like no you
take the small one was there a moment to
you mod that you think about that final
battle scene and you're like that's the
moment that I'm gonna remember it was a
little bit like Avengers when we first
saw them used to hammer and shield
together and like that for me was like
oh what a beautiful use of the you know
those two and their weapons for me and
what I noticed the most is the evolution
of Captain America and he's gone from
not wanting to swear and be such a good
boy to now drop and swear bombs the
whole time he's got not only his shield
which is like in pieces but the hammer
this guy has gone from a very defensive
character to a completely offensive
character in every way I think that when
I look at the the final battle scene
here I see the matriculation of the MCU
in its entirety because it starts out
and caps there front and center and
Tony's there and then we have this what
we're starting to lose and we're
starting to have a lot of gunshot then
all of a sudden the gun turrets just
turn up and they start firing it's
something we're like what the what the
hell is this and then it's Captain
Marvel showing up I think that was the
most significant moment of that battle
scenes to me because it turned the tide
for our heroes but it also entered into
this scene where we have all of the
women of the MCU starting to come
forward and starting to beat the crap
out of all these it was it was pretty
seminal moment like was it trying too
hard
it was so female thirsty either give me
a female Avengers or don't forget this
tz4 play give me what we all want we
even asked the Russo brothers again
about this female you know team up and
they know it's what people are yearning
for get granted the biggest movie on the
planet I'm glad we got that 30 seconds
or so but yeah it's a bit on the nose
she'll have help like I don't you're on
when it happened in the moment and the
movie I was like yes
go Queens but this spider-man say
something they said step aside yes then
they told him to step aside absolutely
like boys this is not your fight this is
ours I get it
but at afterwards I was like I think I
was accessible in infinity war yes yes
organic and this one did feel a little
bit forced and granted it was because we
essentially had a deus ex machina with
with Captain Marvel I mean she literally
kind of did that for a moment and I
think the second time around it didn't
it didn't hit he'll bet she came in like
Damian Lillard did in the recent
Trailblazers gaming I was a sports fan I
can also say that seeing Black Panther
take the take the Infinity Gauntlet and
run with it and then have him throw it
over to Spyder seeing all our different
heroes like have a time with the
Infinity Gauntlet it's like they're
trying to protect it I thought that was
pretty cool to finally scored a
touchdown and it was epic but we did not
get there in a linear fashion we had to
go back in time we had to go to so many
different dimensions we had to go to a
quantum realm to do this the time travel
aspect of it Scott mance I know you've
seen a lot of time travel movies and you
probably are the perfect person to kick
this segment off about the time heist
because you know the release date of
every comic book movie ever made how did
the time travel element in this work for
you when they start going back in time
the movie doesn't just wrap up
everything it falls back unto its own
legacy it falls back onto the first
Avengers movie Thor 2 falls back on to
Winter Soldier which up to this point
was the best movie in the MCU and it
just the way he just fell back onto
itself and they redid some scenes and
and use some of the scenes from these
past movies like that's what I just went
okay the payoff of using the time travel
element is working I'm all in how much
would it be employ'd going ahead in the
MCU mod if we are holding to the future
of the MCU via crotch that should not be
a well we did it wrong zing and I have
the comparison with like video games you
remember arcade games back in the day
you had free lives and that's you know
unless it was contrary yes and then it's
like you know when you died you would
dead and you had to start again now you
can say whenever you want you can
respawn and so you every mistake that
you make you're just starting
and it really like it's not as fun the
stakes are removed from it I just don't
think I mean yeah time travel isn't up
up down down a Vav sort of thing but I
will say this if you think that it's not
gonna come up again I'm sorry two things
are gonna happen again somebody that
died in this course of this thing is
gonna find a way to be living either its
vision or you know what I mean somebody
that looking for is already back yeah
well the boys already yeah exactly a
version of gamora's are you back but
there's going to be that there's going
to be resurrections there's going to be
time travel this is comics and at this
point because no one ever really does
yes exactly do you think that there's a
scenario sky going forward where we
could use this time-travel aspect if we
have this mission and the only guy for
it is a Captain America Steve Rogers in
his prime we go back we say hey Peggy
can we borrow him for the weekend I hope
not and here's why first of all because
I agree with both of you but also it
diffuses it deflates the significance of
that plot device in avengers endgame if
they're going to if they're going to do
anything and bring it up again then
there has to be some sort of like you
know insurance policy where they can say
you know what this was a one-shot deal
we can't do this again
so we mentioned a lot of the cool
time-travel moments lately like Thor
getting to reconnect with his mom Tony
Stark getting to reconnect with his dad
which was a great surprise and one of
the best Stan Lee cameos that we see was
getting to see Stan Lee as this anti-war
protester I love seeing cat fight cat
yeah that was the best scene it was cool
it was fun for me to watch cap be a
little disgusted with how much of a
goody two-shoes and I can do this all
day it's like I get it I Know Who I am
it was so fun to see him purge some of
himself I think oh yes that is America's
ass that was the best part I was saying
cat fighting have was cool there because
everyone's like I love you 3,000 is
gonna be the thing I'm like no it's not
America's ass is gonna be the thing that
people are quoting from this plate
locate that the cat versus cat fight
here is a film 20 second movie in the
MCU we've seen so many great battle
scenes so many great fights over these
last 11 years this was totally
unexpected a big surprise and a movie
that had a lot of surprises that were
big and small but that moment just
everyone everybody in the audience I'm
ready
that premier just went yeah yeah great
but even like when you revisit the
elevator moment you're like I know where
this is we've stated we know how this
guy's down and the way they expelled
hundra so weird Hey he becomes a Nazi in
the common run let's talk about it yeah
it's paying off it's paying off to that
for me though Tony going back and
talking to his dad I felt was more
emotional for me it was actually not the
bigger moments for me it was all of the
smaller little going back to the MCU and
looking at it in a different way Thor
talking to his mother talking to Frieda
and Tony there was a lot of like
maternal paternal like going down into
the generations which i think is very
fitting because when you look at this
film there were people that went on
dates to movies like First Avenger and
iron man who now have been married have
kids that they can now take to go see
endgame and I think there's a lot of
that within the audience I mean there's
a friend of mine who's on Twitter and he
was 12 when the first movie came out and
now he's you know an adult covering it
as part of like his job so I think
having something this long that that's
sort of like long story telling the big
joy of it is people grew up not just
with these movies they grew up like
alongside them and there's memories
attached to their lives so I think those
kind of things were really great and it
gave us a lot of chance to see cameos
from from actors who we've seen so it
felt a little bit like the Seinfeld
finale except and they felt a little bit
like The Family Guy episode where Peter
and Brian go back to the first Family
Guy episode the best moment in the whole
time-travel sequence to me I love seeing
Loki again and I'm very curious to see
how that could transform Loki from this
character that we now miss in the MCU
into somebody who might be on a Disney
streaming service there are all same
things so what we're having at the
moment as soon as you include time
travel you eliminate all consequence oh
yeah there's no stake as no steps that
was the other reason with cap is like
they're like oh well Chris Evans has
done a Mike Isabel because I know he
wants to direct but he could totally
pull a Harrison Ford now because they
left all the time from basically when we
saved the world until Linney shows back
up on that bench we can have all these
adventures in the 1960s and 70s with
like an older Chris Evans that they now
just open that up for that well we just
need our version of plutonium I mean
it's not easy to go back in time
in this world you need those little
thing you need the little red goo that
can get you back in time so you don't
have 28 chica watts
yeah you don't have an unlimited amount
of time travel retcon on some movie
stats Robert Redford's last film is not
old man of the gun anymore it is now
endgame and they kept that like quiet as
Church mice let me tell you I was like
Robert Redford is another movie Marvel
you know all these TV shows that are
gonna be on Disney Plus Falcons gonna
get his own show I mean all these Marvel
characters who really didn't get a whole
lot of time to shine in the films are
gonna it's like Oprah you know you get a
Marvel show you'll get a Marvel show
Plus of it I really think when we talk
about the next chapter if this is the
first chapter in the MCU and it was a
great chapter the reason why the second
one I think is gonna be interesting and
vibrant and is not gonna feel tired is
the Disney Plus of it all the fact that
they're gonna be able to tell parallel
linear stories the fact that we're gonna
have total control over it it's not
going to be something in a different
studio it's gonna be the opposite of
what they tried to do with with both
these Network shows and and Netflix is
that it they they kind of it was a
separation of power it's like well we'll
tell our stories and will reference
what's happening on the big screen but
the big screen does not have to adhere
to anything and now that's no longer
your gonna be the case so a lot of
Disney Plus subscriptions were probably
sold exactly this movie and more
importantly not beholden to ratings let
that's the main reason why I think
that's important but I mean like but
when you look at agents of shield and
agent Carter and when you look at some
of these other shows that had dips or
didn't do as well they the reason why is
because they were beholden to ratings
and people were like oh well if it's not
working well cancel it what was the show
they got cancelled Inhumans like you
know that wasn't a great show but the
whole point is like the Disney Plus of
it they can really control like this is
this we only want to have six episodes
miniseries of Falcon and they could do
that you know and also don't forget here
that even though Black Widow died in
Avengers endgame Scarlett Johansson is
finally getting her own Black Widow
movie and so will that be sort of a it
is a prequel they've said that it's a
prequel it is a pretty much yeah so
there you go you can't have a solo
female superhero movie without making a
prequel so it's talking about the
time-travel right in the movie and then
we talk about the future of where the
you could go with this because we still
have a lot of heavy hitters we still
black panther still spider-man self
Captain Marvel we have Doctor Strange
and like we said all the Disney Plus
services but I think the last thing I
want to get to in this review is the
surprises that weren't maybe earth
shattering or change the legacy the MCU
but some fun stuff like for example the
fact that Hulk like kind of the cool
professor that want to take a selfie
with or was it
but he's still I do love how they also
still made him the professor that
doesn't get it right because remember
the Hulk is the Hulk because Bruce
Banner messed up his experiment and now
Bruce Banner is the Hulk and granted
he's genius and smarter than granted
probably me and everyone I know in the
fictional world but he still can figure
out time travel and he still was messing
that up like he's the failed experiment
he had such a good sense of humor about
he's like let's make a baby
no Jacquelyn you talk about how Captain
America becoming a Nazi was a nod to the
comics and the Hulk having Bruce banners
brain was also a nod to the comics in
the 80s that actually happened and I
thought you know just like Chris
Hemsworth had a chance to evolve playing
Thor by adding levity and humor to it
you know to have Mark Ruffalo I mean he
did in Thor Ragnarok but especially with
this movie adding so much levity because
how many times are you gonna say Hulk
smash so this was a great way and
putting the glasses on he's like yeah
we're at a shirt finally I thought that
was awesome yeah especially like when
you consider what we saw in infinity
wall he he had his sucking moment in
that one where he was just like you know
I I got to feed it and so I'm not gonna
do anything oh yeah we saw this new
dimension of him which was just so
fulfilling I feel yeah it's like the
fact that these characters that we've
known for decades is still evolving am I
getting something new each time I feel
like it would only take Thor about a
week to get back in shape but do we want
to see the Lebowski Thor in a Guardians
movie or Mara are you done with Lebowski
Thor you want him to go back to you
think Chris house works really hot and
you don't like seeing him like that or
absolutely not that Schuyler it is the
fact that it was it was an a disservice
to his integrity as a character I
honestly think that he was fighting he's
and of
Benja and it's like he got the
opportunity to avenge and to go back and
you know but he thinks we're like a
spoiled little rich kid in like
privileged and like I could totally see
like people the first time they faced
adversity a lot of times do not handle
it well and I think that that his like
his like self-destruction as someone
that eats a little bit too many cookies
after the wrong breakup I feel Thor in
that moment I feel him a lot and I can
see how it broke him when you go through
a period of grief of Matt's loss it
takes some people a little bit longer to
get their act together and get back on
their feet and usually it to say this
what it is is like the more adversity
you have maybe even at a young age or
like early on the better equipped you
are to deal with it like and I just
don't think he was well equipped to deal
with it so like how draggy and awful it
was I think that's the reason why like
Hattie had a little bit more like look
cap was cap he was a little skinny guy
that was getting beat up everywhere he
was he just comes back for more no
matter what Thor went with who who mess
with him for more than like you know a
20 minute runtime you know all this I do
if you told me a week ago that the
biggest debate topic on Avengers endgame
would be doing like Lebowski Thor but
that is gonna do it for this episode of
the after show I do want to throw it to
my panel it's just very quickly give me
a one-sentence kind of encapsulation of
everything that avengers endgame meant
to you I'll start with you mom this is
the perfect way to say goodbye to 20
year 21 previous films and storytelling
and the respect that they showed
characters in this was just so so well
done that it is almost the perfect movie
to see how factor father's got back the
father kind of I'm gonna build on your
on your case there by saying that what
we have seen now with this Marvel
Cinematic Universe these 22 films these
last 11 years is unprecedented in the
history of Hollywood in the history of
movies even going back to a hundred
years 8090 years to the days of RKO and
Warner Brothers you know and 20th
Century Fox like Hollywood has never
seen the likes of what we have now
experienced and that is a tip of the hat
to the vision the
bold vision of Kevin Feige the president
of Marvel Studios and the producer of
these films like the way he built up to
phase one in the face - and he's moving
around all the different standalone
films like chess pieces and you have
Thor showing up in in or you have the
Hulk showing up in thor ragnarok you
have Iron Man showing up and spider-man
homecoming it is you know we're in it so
we don't have the perspective yet but we
are still in in the middle of something
that is unprecedented in the analysis of
Hollywood Jack when you did wear a
funeral dress to the premiere of Ed and
let's let's be honest we buried some
bodies and I loved it but I'll put is
you this way I want to leave you with
things that that the MCU did and one of
them is really interesting up until this
point it often felt like we got to get
all the characters together for us to
feel we have a story by doing what they
did with the MCU at this point by
introducing so many character is getting
us invested in them giving some of them
new TV shows going forward you're not
gonna need that Avengers Assemble for
people to be invest in that's a miracle
like let's talk about if you know every
side character of other franchises would
love it if people like no people will
show up for you know vision and Scarlet
Witch people are gonna show up for a
Loki TV show and it's because they
waived this sort of like MCU tablet into
are basically the like like the
zeitgeist of pop culture everybody loves
these characters they don't care if it's
just two of them the second thing which
i think is incredible after you watch
endgame it is a towering achievement of
cinema of just moviemaking it's gonna
make billions of dollars I advise you to
go back and watch
age of Ultron which is a film that gets
unfairly maligned in my person because
go back and look at what they set up and
so many of these moments that we love
that we're so satisfying in this movie
which is to me the tagline for what it
is we're set up an age of Ultron we got
what Conda we got so we got cap like
chugging the hammer like a little bit
and that's how we knew that they were
gonna do it
watch that literally when you leave in
game go back and see that is when the
MCU became the MC I completely agree and
when you're watching end games you've
realized that everything that came
before in these 21 movies big moments
small moments everything
had a purpose and if you've been paying
attention like you were then you will be
duly rewarded over and over again but my
question for you if I can just take over
for one second here is where it does
Avengers and game rank in these 22 MCU
movies that perspective is gonna have to
be saved for another day I think it's
probably my top 5 or my top 10 but like
Professor Coley just gave me homework
now I have to go watch Avengers age of
Ultron yeah I think regardless of where
you rank this movie in your favorite MCU
films of all time I think that a huge
shout out has to go to you the fans
because y'all are the reason why these
movies continue to get made because you
support them so fervently and we'd love
to hear from you on this vid right now
so comment let us know your thoughts on
the ventures endgame and this is the
spoiler talk so have at it let it rip
let us know what you loved what you
didn't love what your favorite moment
was what you thought maybe could have
done a little bit better and make sure
you guys subscribe right here and click
that bell it'll give you an alert every
time we have a new one of the after
shows coming up on a future Saturday
because there's a lot of big movies
coming up this summer we cannot wait to
share our thoughts with all of you
boremont Garrett Scott Matz and
Jacqueline Kohli I'm Mark Ellis we'll
see you guys soon on the after-show
[Music]
[Music]